good morning my rural chum mr. dr.
robotnik I'm going to give you five
seconds so first of all I are on this
year at CinemaCon you said that you
liked you really liked playing Robotnik
for a couple of reasons you said you got
to explore a new side of yourself and
hit any absurd energy people love yeah
so I'm wondering what did you find out
about yourself playing this role I'm not
that smart
created video games but the wonderful
thing about it is you know I can be
really lousy at this video game and
still win because I'm no I'm Robotnik
you are so literally I when I see the
big machine Robotnik coming by I just I
just rammed sonic into him over and over
again until the ghost flies off the game
grid he's such an iconic character yeah
loved by the Sonic oh jeez yeah and
you've played so many iconic characters
so how did you approach Robotnik
basically I you know I believe that
light you and I don't have to believe it
it's true scientifically lightning
starts from the ground so that's the
same with a character with this kind of
character is like I had to find that
evil genius
the combination of absolute intelligence
and and total worthlessness in his own
mind you know that combination is deadly
and we're seeing a lot of it you know
they're seeing a lot of it it sounds
like billionaires it's not Hollywood
it's everywhere it's everywhere so you
know that's a wonderful combination to
play plus the idea of AI freaking
everybody out you know they're putting
chips in people's heads and you know
Alexa is spying on you and watching you
and saying you might want to change your
underwear I know in the film to sort of
display sonic speed yeah they have
everything else freeze around him
because he's so quick right your humor
is so quick when you're in a scene is
everything frozen around you what do you
experience when you're going out
lightning buddies dumbfounded
well generally you know generally it
goes a the world spins for me it's it's
wild I my world is a game grid and I I
look at it like every little segment
every little moment like this moment
with you is the only thing that is right
and then there's something else and then
the next moment is the only thing that
is and I try to like completely dedicate
myself to those moments and bring
whatever I can to those moments and I'm
the same way when I perform I I'm in my
hotel room I'm walking in a circle I'm
saying the lines to myself and I learn
them and then my brain starts creating
and screws up all my learning and I the
next thing you know I've dreamt about it
I've walked you know over breakfast I
have some ideas and then I come in with
20 new ideas you know a third of which I
can remember the rest are on little
cards like tied up everywhere you know
and it's like you know whatever's in my
consciousness whatever gets my attention
becomes part of the show so sonic has a
bucket list in this movie are you
because you do what you're just saying
is just living in the moment
do you have bucket lists are there
things that you really want to do want
to explode into a ball of light do you
yes yeah that's big yeah that's a big
one number one yes nothing else comes
out yeah I want to awaken spiritually
over and over again and then go back to
sleep and hit the snooze alarm is there
something you've accomplished something
bucket list ish that you have done I am
literally black and blue with pinch
marks you know from my life it is a
constant surprise a constant just just a
gratitude soup
honest to god every bite of it I just go
I can't believe I'm here I can't believe
I get to do what I do I love my audience
I love what I do and I get to do not
only that I get to produce a TV show and
star on it I get I get to write a novel
you know slash memoir that's coming
and may I get to become a cartoonist and
an artist and actually be taken
seriously that way and contribute in New
York and Playboy magazines and it is an
embarrassment of riches and
opportunities and and prosperity and
abundance and I honestly I feel like I'm
and I say this all the time I talk about
mangoes
I look at it like like life has just
become a gigantic mango tree and I'm
sitting underneath it and they're just
falling all around me and and it's
wonderful you made a joke about your
haircut how it took seven haircuts to
grow out yes so I wanted to say from
women everywhere who have had bad
haircuts we fully appreciate what you've
gone through well they cut that you know
that part into my hair it was it was a
nice big thick swath and it screwed
everything I think you know they wanted
it to be seen from outer space or
something I don't know but you
understand what women go through oh yes
I can't say I totally understand the
world's largest rubber band bulb we
gotta see it know this is not some fun
family road trip you're right it was
lame gift shop was cool though this is a
movie reference people have to see the
movie to understand this although it is
in the trailer it is if you go to
fandango's twitter it's there there and
it's like you're on our twitter too cuz
you retweet it I know and I was very sad
you you posted a clip today that
although I don't know when this coming
out but you posted a clip how do you do
it you do it this way I do it that way
but I'm Canadian oh oh you post it
you're very good at it
yeah shortened your string so you'd be
better than me I thought you posted a
clip today that was so excited did
because it's the speech but there's a
line in it that I tried to copy Jim
Carrey's performance in Dumb and Dumber
stop it so there's a line that he does
were in Dumb and Dumber where he's like
he's talking about this thing this thing
then he goes our pets heads are falling
off we got no food got no jobs our pets
Hector fought and I did that for this I
go I got a fish on my head
I'm wet
I'm cold there's a fish on my head
we had fans pick their most iconic sonic
lines like the ocean are you kidding me
I mean you need glasses like this to
read that no I want you to tie it you
want me to do Sonic yes okay okay you
might know everything I'm gonna do but
that's not gonna help you since I know
everything you're gonna do strange isn't
it
I found you faker I'll make you eat
those words you're too slow and what's
this one been dangos great that's not
from a cartoon show you are the master
improper because that was not on the
that was not on the car my goodness well
that just that was incredible watching
that you all really in the path I'm in
the paddleboard it's a credible watching
it because it's hard to do it's a really
hard to do do it but you've done a
couple of voices before so how did you
change it up for this one and and and
did you pay homage to the originals how
did you sure yes oh they're incredible
voiceover actors that have done this
voice there's a Roger Craig there's
Julie oh there's Ryan there's Jason
there's a long list of income people and
people who've done Robotnik man there's
some great robotic voices out there but
the way that I did it was I play the
video games one more time and then I
read the script in my head the way that
the script played was like it's like
this young kid there's so much energy
who's never been allowed out of this
cave finally gets out as K gets to do
whatever he does and he's so excited so
I kind of just played it like a little
kid that's finally so excited to do
whatever he wanted to do and that just
happens to look like that's when you're
watching the movie you feel the warmth
in connection between Tom and this
character cuz it feels like a real
little boy you know what I have that's
kind of where I was becoming wow I have
that oh great and I playing the video
game that wasn't really research was it
you just want to know I remember
literally when I got the role I was like
oh I can write off that I've already
bought sonic mania I guess now it's a
business expense there was a lot of talk
about bucket list in this movie so did
you check off a bucket list I don't play
anything language is to be Sonic a
character that I've loved growing up the
other one to be in a movie that stars
Jim Carrey that's something that if you
asked me as a kid I couldn't even dream
that big I never thought I'd be doing
any of this I was a psych anthro major
so the idea that any of this is
happening is above and beyond I feel
very very lucky so I know you're a gamer
huge gamer so for the og Sonic fans what
are they gonna find in this movie that
they're
laughs I mean I could tell you specific
Easter eggs if you want okay there's
some there's some Easter eggs in the
game there's one that if you're Sonic
and you go narrow ledge she goes like
this in the movie in the hotel scene
there's that if you look at his bandana
when he's playing with his nunchucks the
old emblem of the start screen is there
and there's a bunch of different ones
that I won't talk about now but I think
what the cool thing that Jeff and all
everybody didn't the writers did is that
they reward the fans that have been
there for a while with all these funny
Easter eggs and they they they help
introduce Sonic in a way that if you've
never seen this before you still get to
love it because it's got action comedy
drama heart Jim Carrey and it kind of
comes together in this fun beautiful way
clearly I'm not gonna be able to do this
on my own
alright get in the truck
really help me I guess it is a little
bit my fault that all this is happening
to you not a little bit entirely it is
entirely your fault it's entirely my
fault
are you coming yes road trip what am i
doing so this opens on Valentine's Day
right it's such a you know
counterintuitive to Valentine's Day but
why is this the perfect Valentine's
weekend movie why is it because I think
that at the core of every good
relationship is a friendship but but
yeah maybe for all the people who don't
want to do this sort of straight down
the line what you're supposed to do on
Valentine's Day you know go see a fun
movie that you can both laugh and laugh
at together this movie laughs with yes
alone every memory preposition you can
think of so you are so phenomenal in
this movie oh thank you and what I
always do whenever I watch a movie that
has CGI characters I'm looking for the
cracks I'm looking for when the actor I
can tell there's no CGI do the same
couldn't see any with you I would that
was like my goal I was like I wanted to
make them feel like this is real and
sometimes the camera operators would be
like I just look over here I'm like no
no I don't know exactly where his eyes
are like because you can tell if you're
looking 15 feet in the distance or two
feet alright your eyes sort of
triangulate anyway well good I'm glad
you
the same way yeah so just also for you
and you're on the day did you have
voices did they play voices did you play
against them yes there was there was a
gentleman there who was a really
talented and funny guy who was reading
opposite made but he was hidden I
couldn't hear him
he knew he got to kind of got the sense
of Ben's sensibilities and his comic
timing and he was a great help when Ben
wasn't there and too just so that there
was someone reading the lines with you
and created the the rhythm of the scene
but as far as something to look at it
was nothing like there was no I tried to
get Ben in a full blue spandex
he was busy and too tall turns out that
have been great for like the extra
that's on the DVD maybe there will be so
I know you're a bit of a gamer you were
or at least you were a bit of a game or
what what do you think the og fans of
Sonic are gonna appreciate about this
movie I think they're gonna love you
know cuz look that there's certain
there's a certain ethology with the game
and certain lore that that we expanded
upon to make it a film right so like the
storyline some of those things weren't
you know it's sonic never spoke and the
video games right and so Ben Schwartz is
voicing him but I think the fans who
grew up playing the game are gonna love
seeing seeing the character come to life
right he now has a voice he now has a
personality he's cocky he sort of he's
sarcastic but there's an innocence of
purity to him and and it's like you know
it's anybody who loves something growing
up that existed in a two-dimensional
world you know seeing his step into the
third dimension and come to life tell me
about your childhood
yeah and hearing the Ching of when he
gets the Rings like all those like
nostalgic like markers that just make
you happy and bring you back to your
childhood for you what were those games
was it Sonic would and what are the
other ones that maybe would make a great
movie yeah that's a good question I was
like 18 or 19 when Sonic came out I was
still video gaming but I was I started
with Atari and computer games like oh
that old that Commodore 64 and like the
Intellivision and the Nintendo and Super
Nintendo
I mean I spent the games I spent the
most time on we're probably the original
Mario Brothers sonic and gold and I love
it yeah Goldeneye that was the first
like first-person shooter kind of thing
and I spent way too many hours playing
that I had to quit I had to quit all
video games did you really yeah cuz I
just would get sucked I would just not
get anything done and I would just get
sucked in and if four hours would pass
like that and so I have a great place in
my heart for video gamers for video
games period sonic is one of the great
iconic characters and special thing to
bring them to the big screen whatever
this creature is I'm going to uncover
the source its power
[Music]
you